et
un dragon dans les rues de montargis
comme chaque année la ville célèbre le
nouvel an chinois la chine et montargis
c'est à la fois une histoire d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui
celle d'une amitié profonde entre des
lycéens est aussi celle d'une poignée de
jeunes chinois qui ont révolutionné un
cinquième de la planète
montargis est en quelque sorte la porte
d'entrée vers la france de ce groupe de
gens dont le rôle a pu être considéré
comme décisif par la suite c'est
vraiment le la porte d'entrée le passage
premier et c'est ce qui à ce qui a
constitué la filière première qui leur a
permis de venir
tout a commencé il ya plus d'un siècle
li shi zen y un fils demande à reims où
la chine a perial arrive en france en
1903 pour étudier au lycée agricole du
chesnois à montargis de retour en chine
il fonde le mouvement travail études il
est à l'origine des filières ce qu'on
peut appeler une filière c'est à dire ce
qui apparaîtra comme un des moyens pour
des jeunes chinois intellectuelle plus
ou moins en difficulté d'aller étudier à
l'étranger et plus particulièrement en
france près de 2000 jeunes chinois vous
débarquez à marseille après la première
guerre mondiale près de 300 séjourneront
à montargis où li shi zen y avait tissé
un véritable réseau d'amitiés et parmi
eux des amis de mao
dans la cour du lycée en forêt de
montargis le cours de gym a du succès ça
c'est un truc et on a fait un petit
badge barça au lycée du pouvoir voici
génial quoi ça fait partie du jeu te
d'aller vers la culture de l'autre ça
c'est amusant de découvrir un peu tout
ce qu'ils font le matin c'est sa mise en
chauffe
c'est une tradition les élèves chinois
de change à la capitale du coup man sont
accueillis par le lycée en forêt de
montargis grâce à la ténacité de
powerwise et la professeure de mode
arrière assis au lycée c'était une porte
grande ouverte pour enfin surtout pour
ce prêt ouverte pour les horaires voire
différentes choses je trouve que les
jeunes français sont très studieux ils
font beaucoup d'efforts dire ce sympa et
plutôt aujourd'hui les élèves de chant
cha au rendez vous avec leur histoire au
musée chine montargis des photos des
documents retracent la vie de ces jeunes
idéalistes chinois pour la plupart venus
du rhône alpes ce sont des gens de notre
lycée au run and qui sont venus et cet
épisode doit inspirer la jeune
génération dans notre programme
d'histoire on ne peut pas tout abordé
mais après cette visite sur le terrain
en rentrant ben on va détailler cette
période je pense que ça va beaucoup
aider les élèves en fait avant de venir
en france
j'ai consulté les archives / montargis
j'ai trouvé beaucoup de documents sur
cette histoire sur internet mais dans
les articles c'est très succinct ici
j'ai pu apprendre beaucoup plus de
choses
il ya des détails tout ça me touche
beaucoup
en tant que chinois
six duels l'idée même de faire la
révolution n'a pas encore germé dans
l'esprit de ces jeunes intellectuels
néanmoins en quête de changement la
plupart viennent déjà est un projet
politique c'est pas un projet politique
clair
au contraire ils ont deux vagues notions
de ce que ça pouvait être le socialisme
ou la transformation ou la modernisation
ou des choses comme ça donc c'est pas
c'est pas clair dans leur esprit ça va
se fixer petit à petit soit par les
lectures qui rit qui réussissent à faire
soit je dirais pour une partie d'entre
eux par la découverte coup concrète de
ce que c'est qu'une société développe
et/ou de ce que c'est que le travail
il étudie au collège gambetta pour les
garçons et au collège chansons pour les
filles pour financer leurs études
beaucoup d'entre eux travaillent talent
usine une chine sonne à montargis leur
sang n'est pas si mauvais ainsi c'est
plutôt par la suite quand ils quitteront
mentale puisque les choses vont se gâter
pour eux parce que à montargis il a été
prévu pour que les classes
d'apprentissage du français b2 qui sont
de formation générale serait ouverte il
ya même des classes ouvertes places
ouvertes pour les filles donc s'ils sont
encadrés sur le plan pédagogique et on a
prévu de leur trouver des logements dans
des dortoirs donc une manière générale
là ça ça ne va pas trop mal parmi les
premiers arrivés à montargis il y a cinq
résonne c'est un brillant théoricien qui
correspond régulièrement avec mao rester
en chien
les jeunes chinois se retrouvent à
montargis dans le square d'urzy en
juillet 1920 il organiste ici une
réunion qui a pour nom sauver la chine
sauvé le monde le 20 août
saizen écrit une lettre célèbre à mao où
il propose la création du parti
communiste chinois
je n'ai rien contre répond pas aux
quelques mois plus tard arrive à
montargis celui qui restera comme l'un
des plus grands dirigeants chinois deng
xiaoping pour tout le groupe qui se
trouvait en france et d'où sortiront
quand même un certain nombre des
dirigeants importants
c'est le moment où ils ont décidé que
c'est effectivement ça la solution
politique qu'ils allaient adopter c'est
ce qu'il fallait comme solution aux
problèmes de la chine alors tartiflette
parce qu'il fait très froid tu viens me
plongeant matin j'ai pour les lycéens de
montargis apprendre le chinois est une
chance très peu d'établissements le
propose et comment ce vraiment une
nouvelle langue n'est un peu long c'est
comme ça mais en même temps le fait
sortir et j'ai aimé bien aimé bien à
l'aise dès le début et il pourrait après
pour remonter le niveau peuple d'un côté
comme de l'autre on s'amuse des
différences ouais mais en ce qui
concerne l'alimentation
il ya énormément de différences au
niveau des repas durant la journée et
pour la vie quotidienne les européens
prennent leur douche le matin
les chinois eux se lave le soir et le
matin si du vent mais si dieu est gelé
on a des a priori par rapport aux
chinois c'est des gens un peu fermé un
peu et en fait c'est des gens qui sont
très très ouvert très son drôle il est
là beaucoup d'humour
finalement on si c'est une culture qui
est tellement différente de la nôtre on
aurait pu avoir beaucoup plus de
problèmes et finalement ça se passe très
bien
pour leur dernier jour en france les
lycéens de chang sa visite chambord l'un
des joyaux du val de loire
bienvenue à chambord nous nous serions
heureux de vous accueillir à chambord
l'un des seuls château a proposé une
brochure en mandarin solendi ce que je
voudrais dire en premier c'est que je
suis très impressionné très impressionné
il est magnifique et l'environnement est
très beau nos visiteurs chinois sont
heureux d'avoir les clés pour saisir les
subtilités de ce chef-d'oeuvre de la
renaissance avec les explications
chinois on connaît maintenant les pièces
leur utilité l'emplacement des meubles
ses tableaux et statues et bien sûr
toutes les histoires derrière on
comprend beaucoup mieux
exemple le château est beau
bon je sais qu'on lui pose pas
non
juste milieu
à
on tient bon pour la nature en twittant
chan chan 7 millions d'habitants la
capitale du yunnan au sud est de la
chine
une mégalopole en perpétuelle expansion
et surtout le berceau du communisme
chinois d'où sont issus à un grand
nombre d'intellectuels qui ont séjourné
à montargis championnat est aussi la
patrie de mao tsé toung
ce fils de paysans aisés ne quittera pas
la chair
il reste à changer au lycée numéro un
celui là même qui accueille à son tour
les élèves français pour l'occasion
l'établissement reçoit la visite du
consul de france
le diplomate est convaincu de
l'importance de l'histoire chinoise de
montargis ça joue un rôle très important
parce que la mentalité chinoise une
mentalité de temps long et mentalité de
l'inscription dans la tradition d'amitié
et à l'expression chinois c'est
l'accompagnement ça veut dire
c'est très important de se connaître
depuis longtemps c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui c'est d'anciennes
relations sont aussi un espace très
importante pour construire des relations
aujourd'hui il est bien fait de l'
échange le proviseur du lycée numéro un
en est persuadé c'est une chance un
tremplin un lien pour que les élèves des
deux écoles communiquent entre eux il
découvre ce qu'il y a de bien chez
l'autre noir brillant
au coeur de chant cha se trouve la
maison de saint nazaire le grand ami de
mao
il est venu en france pour étudier tout
en travaillant il est venu à montargis
dans le centre il était à l'école
gambetta pour les garçons tout en
travaillant à un an après avec ma où ils
se sont rencontrés à changsha et il
aimait bien partager leurs idées en fait
il voulait changer la chine et le monde
cette image c'est un montage i c est
devant l'école de gambetta
actuellement c'est un guéridon montage y
connaissez ça irait zen qui est à
montargis l'idée de créer un parti
communiste en chine sera un rédacteur en
chef du journal du pc chinois et mourad
36 ans exécuté par le parti national
c'est la famille du professeur de gym
qui accueille hasina élèves de première
à montargis homeland un plein de fait
les raviolis il m'avait y tient il faut
fabriquer des raviolis tous les jours
ciao six mois aux mains c'est plutôt
pour la fête du printemps 40 chez toi
depuis longtemps j'avais rêvé de visiter
la tâche est donc ça m'a fait plaisir de
recevoir une chinoise voir comment enfin
son quotidien
puis quand je suis ici bas j'ai eu comme
en plein le genre de vie quotidienne y
avait et puis ça je trouve que c'est
assez impressionnant en fait non on est
beaucoup plus dans la rapidité et
prennent leur temps et puis m'ont dit
que les chinois aussi ils vont assez
vite et tout mais c'est ils sont beaux
lots nous sommes tous des ambassadeurs
de l'amitié franco-chinoise
j'espère que la france et la chine
auront toujours de bonnes relations dans
le futur une francophilie partagé par
toute la famille quand j'étais en france
j'ai pu apprécier la culture française
et j'ai témoigné lors des 50 ans de la
relation franco-chinoise à montargis
après j'ai vraiment senti la sympathie
des français envers nous
non
aujourd'hui la journée est consacrée à
mao le petit père du peuple est vénéré h
à une sculpture lui rend hommage sur
l'île de l'oranje au milieu de la
rivière xiang qui traverse la ville et
malgré les millions de morts de la
révolution culturelle
les chinois viennent ici en pèlerinage
fâché aux malades
c'est un grand leader en chine il fait
partie de la première génération de
dirigeants de la chine nouvelle c'est
lui qui a permis au pays de se
transformer ici c'est ça vient le natal
et on vient pour s'imprégner de son
histoire la personnalité de mao tsé
toung une réalité complexe et difficile
à saisir pour des lycéens français
d'après les chinois c'est celui qui
a eu beaucoup d'influencé au niveau 2
république mais il a fait des erreurs
mais malgré ça il a les a donnés il est
pardonné
la journée se poursuit avec la visite de
la maison natale de mao à 40km de champ
de shah dans le village de shah au chan
qui est devenu un véritable lieu de
culte
ici à part les lycéens de montargis pas
de touristes étrangers mais des milliers
de chinois qui arrivent par bus de tout
le pays
certains s'offre même une déposent deux
gerbes au pied du grand timonier
il a été la première personne dans
l'histoire chinoise défendre les libérer
le chinois de base beaucoup de personnes
de condition très modeste pour qu'elle
ait une vie pleine de lumière et de
bonheur
retour à chante chat pour le concours
annuel de chorales qui voit s'affronter
28 classes du lycée numéro un selon des
styles très différents
pour les lycéens de montargis pas facile
de se mesurer aux chinois à la hauteur
des chinois parce que nous on n'a pas de
costumes on a rien c'est moins bien
préparé quand même la même voie on n'est
pas une vraie chorale quoi donc on en
produit
ce
pour clôturer leur séjour à chante chez
les lycéens de montargis ont été
autorisés à visiter le musée du parti
communiste chinois
un lieu très important pour la province
du yunnan
samassi culte de la personnalité chou
sar présent vachement la personnalité de
ma haute simplement les fibres le
communisme en général ils avaient l'idée
de changer la chine au début ils ont
fait suivre cette idée donc je trouve
que c'est fin c'est fort quand il s'agit
de commenter l'évolution du parti
communiste chinois
la critique n'est pas de mise lynas au
tipex enseignante a sauvé la au début du
20e siècle et demi la chine était semi
colonisé donc la tâche principale des
jeunes chinois à cette époque
ce matin c'était de changer le destin du
pays maintenant ce qui compte pour le
parti communiste
c'est de continuer dans cette direction
est de rendre le peuple heureux si
l'objectif final est donc le même tania
n'étiez 61 tombes molson rosatom mer une
salle du musée est consacrée au séjour
des jeunes chinois à montargis un
épisode qui a été réintégrée récemment
dans l'histoire officielle chinoise
c'était un épisode qui jusqu'aux années
80 et est totalement occulté
il fallait pas en parler cet état c'est
ce sont des années les années de la
révolution culturelle qui aurait été
très difficile
d'une part pour ceux qui étaient à
l'étranger et d'autre part pour leur
famille manière générale l'expatriation
était mal vue sur la révolution
culturelle et donc ces quelques jours
dont on ne parle absolument pas et tout
d'un coup avec l'émergence au premier
plan de doc jean ping après la mort de
cet homme est bien c'est quelque chose
qui tout d'un coup ils devenus
clé d'accès au ping qui n'étaient pas
originaires du rhône ain est arrivée à
montargis un peu après les amis de mao
il travaille lui aussi chez hutchinson à
châlette sur loing avant de séjourner en
union soviétique
après la mort de mao en 1978 deng
xiaoping prend les commandes de la
république populaire de chine et va
ouvrir le pays sur l'occident et
l'économie de marché
son séjour en france prend à leur valeur
de symbole et en 2014
la place de la gare de montargis et
rebaptisé à son nom
au lycée numéro 1 de chant cha les
élèves du lycée en forêt partagent leur
dernier repas avec leurs correspondants
chinois c'est l'heure des bilans
c'est des gens adorables qui veulent
toujours te servir en premier qui sont
toujours là porter etc
il y avait la grand mère de mon
correspondant qui me donnait des pommes
tous les soirs un jour hamon a donné 3 4
alors que j'en voulais plus mais non
c'est j'ai vraiment freiner les gens que
c'est la meilleure chose qui me soit
arrivée déjà parce que c'est une famille
super sympa on a fait tellement de
choses et puis ils sont super fins ya
même pas d'adjectifs pour les qualifiés
en fait s'ils sont ils sont proches
ils sont super reproche en fait et puis
ils me font sentir que je suis leur
fille et j'ai une deuxième famille aussi
après ce séjour où ils ont progressé en
mandarin tous sont convaincus d'avoir
fait le bon choix pour l'avenir
j'aimerais bien avouer que ça puisse
m'aider pour plus tard ça change
accueilli chinois c'était aussi pour
cette raison c'est pour après trop de
tares dans les études si ça pouvait me
servir et
c'est vrai que quand
bah c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas forcément
envie de repartir avec ils sont
tellement gentils pendant pas forcément
envie de dire au revoir tout de suite
l'heure du départ approche et les
séparations sont difficiles
entre l' empire seles des montargis
l'histoire se répète
si l'idée d'une chine nouvelle et en
partie n'est dans le gâtinais il y a
près d'un siècle
aujourd'hui ce sont les jeunes français
qui repartent plus riches de cette
relation unique
et si singulière